how's gone see ya it's very nice to see
you again um you have been wanting to
make this movie since 2013 no longer I
actually got it goes falling back to
2002 to be honest like in 2002 we were
we were making jackass the first jackass
movie and we were all reading that book
and just passing that book around and we
were so also into it and we were making
the movie with MTV Films over at
Paramount an empty MTV Films option that
that book and so I was like hey man if
you need a director I'll direct it
meanwhile I don't know what the hell I'm
doing with Jackie I don't know how to
make a movie but uh I threw my hat into
the ring sort of jokingly and they
didn't take it very serious but then
fast forward to 2010 I sort of lost
track of what was happening with the
dirt and it didn't happen over at
Paramount and I got an an email from my
agent who said hey are you interested in
ru Malik roof and I'm like holy [ __ ]
it's coming like I said get me that I
have to do this and so in 2010 right
after jackass 3 I put together a
lookbook and just pulled images from
different movies and photographers and
just put together a book showing what I
wanted to do with this movie and cut
together a sizzle reel and went pinched
it - the two producers
Erik Olson Julie horn won them over and
then the sonority you got to get
approval from each of the band members
so I had to go and sell myself to Nicky
first and then Tommy and then Vince and
then Meg so I was gonna say it's but
it's it's been it's usually when things
are in development hell for this long it
never happens right it's amazing that
Netflix stepped in and said we're making
this an awesome like look so in in 2011
when I got awarded this gig by the
producers in the band I'm like this is
gonna be my first script in there this
is it thinking it's gonna happen in the
next it's not realizing it's gonna take
eight years but I committed to this be
my first script in there this is the one
I want to tell and I stuck to it and
yeah here we are thank God next Netflix
came through and made it real easy I'm
very curious they're they have so much
material in terms of the music how did
you decide what songs were those songs
that had to be in the film and which
songs came close it's funny because my
favorite Motley Crue song isn't even in
the movie wild side is my favorite and I
wanted it in the movie but as we were
putting together most of the songs lands
chronologically where they belong
but we didn't have room for wild times
but what I am did you have any sort of
could you do anything you wanted and it
was a question now you know what I mean
like how did you decide on Lighting's so
they that their catalog was available to
me like they'd said pick the songs that
you think tell the story it's there was
a bunch of obvious ones that are gonna
be in this movie but past that no one
was telling making me put this on you
know that song it was really just what
works for the story and what works in
the Edit you know completely so yeah for
us it's like all right well this
official for me like livewire I had to
get that right and that became sort of
the young days anthem like that's how
they each audition with that song we go
on and on like having that catalog
available to play with was amazing the
thing about Motley Crue and you had this
wealth of video you have all these
videos all the behind the scenes footage
the band is still alive and they can
tell you things I would imagine like
picking the moments that you want to
feature in the film it's like it is so
much to pick from that talked a little
bit about whittling it all down so it
helps having this book that's filled
with just amazing crazy story after
amazing and horrifying crazy stories
sure so that's what you start there but
but yeah to whittle it down that book is
covering 30 years of Motley Crue we sort
of narrowed it down to the first save 15
years really 10 and then
a little bit after but uh so that that
helped narrow it down and give it some
focus but it was hard you know and we
started off with all the stories and
wanted to tell them all then it slowly
boiled it down to really the ones that
made sense in the whole arc of the movie
with Netflix you have they do series so
well they do movie so well was there
ever any talk once it went over to
Netflix about do we want to do this is
like a four-part one-hour thing you know
I thought that would be cool but we what
we already had the script by then we
refined this script over you know and
being attached to thing for nine years
has gone through a lot of iterations but
we had it pretty much narrowed down to
this is a story we want to tell and so
it was ready to go as a feature the
editing room is ultimately the final
rewrite I'm curious how the film changed
in the editing room and how much was
left on the cutting room floor well it
changed immensely in the Edit room
they're like three honesty's you see it
on the page first then you see the
actors do it and then you find it in the
Edit Bay and it changed a lot we did not
there's there are some scenes on the
floor some good scenes that were very
hard to kill but in the better of the
hole you have to kind of kill some of
your favorites but but there's not
there's not a ton of footage on the
floor like we were pretty specific about
what we were shooting and in the time
frame we we got it pretty much narrowed
down so one of the things about Netflix
is that I think they're amazing I love
what they do
but there's they don't really offer a
lot of deleted scenes they don't do a
lot of commentaries right have you had
that conversation with them about I love
this scene is there any way we can
release it somehow to promote the movie
now I haven't talked about that I love
for me it's not even that it's some
deleted scenes but it's a lot of the
yeah I don't know what to do with all
the behind the scenes stuff we have
we've amassed like all my other projects
we're always rolling on stuff we have
some real fun behind the scenes stuff
that hopefully gets released in the
marketing of this my last thing for you
of course is what was it like
celebrating your director photographies
birthday every day while you were
filming I can you explain what tell what
this was
yeah Toby is this very earnest awesome
guy and you know when you go to a
restaurant you make that joke like it's
his birthday
sure so the first day we met makes what
we all went out to dinner me and a
couple of producers and Toby went in New
Orleans and I just whispered to the
waiter it's just birthday then the
waiter brings over this cake and he's
like oh it's not my birthday
and he was like nah Mike Shh Joey like
you're gonna get a free cake he was like
but it's not my birthday and his
reaction was just so funny that we just
did it every day till we decorate his
office and then every set we made
everybody come sing happy I'm sure he
loved you
I'm annoying right I got to stop there
congratulation thank you I'm so happy
you got to finally make this appreciate
you